[Music]
one of the first acting jobs I ever got
in my life was right out of college I
got a job in a play that my friend and
my former professor Mark Steven wrote
called good night captain white it's a
comedy you can actually still see it in
Salem Massachusetts don't worry about it
and it's a comedy but I'm gonna tell you
the story about the biggest laugh we
ever got in that show it was very very
funny
but the biggest laugh was something that
was not in the play I was the cop and I
was arresting the person accused of
murder and while I was doing it I
pointed the guy he stood up and he was
wearing like Knickerbocker pants like
silky knickerbockers and underneath
white tights very smooth white tights
and my friend Matt was playing the
character had recently lost quite a bit
of weight I don't know if you see where
this is headed in front of a sold-out
house in Salem Massachusetts he stood up
being arrested anyone I never had his
pants slid down like that's what they
were designed to do just so fast so fast
you didn't even see it happening they
were just on his ankles he didn't notice
he didn't notice until the crowd started
going nuts the biggest laugh all the
work all the rehearsal and the polish we
had put in this production suddenly
everyone's going nuts we turned a small
Theatre in Salem into like an evening at
the Apollo you understand people are
doing backflips lighting mattresses on
fire running around in the aisles it was
the biggest laugh I've ever heard in my
life and I'm a professional comedian it
was so funny just a man would fall again
know again and again and again and again
and then he just had to bunch him and
like it was like a towel getting out of
the shower whoo it was so funny we just
ended the show
we ended it was a murder mystery it was
a whodunit and he never told them who
did it it was just like some guy killed
some guy then that guy's pants fell down
the end zero resolution that's what I
realize that like it or not that is the
funniest kind of comedy when something
unexpected or horribly embarrassing
happens to someone and then you laugh
uncontrollably so you think you're gonna
have like an involuntary urine
evacuation nobody I call this kind of
comedy
oops comedy and it's the best sure it's
not the smartest type of comedy but I
say don't fight it I say enjoy it own it
it doesn't matter
like if I ever saw someone actually step
on a rake not in a cartoon in real life
to some man enjoying his own lawn huh oh
it's a good spring and just like that I
would laugh so hard it would be like I
was running out of air on Mars Total
Recall styles of laughter that's how
that's all it would take what just that
and if you're not laughing
you're not picturing your dad go ahead
there's your dad he's in a rush
you're all in your station wagon waiting
for him and he's in a hell of a mood
he's locking the door he's just like ah
we don't leave someone the traffic the
six flags are gonna be happy and God
help you if there's a second-rank
Sideshow Bob styling like I told you to
put the right Bob who left these rakes
out if that happened he would be set on
joy for the month it wouldn't matter
what happened to you you would always
have that simple hilarious memory
getting fired just like I have dedicated
my life to this company my dad stepped
on them rakes be in your pocket for the
rest of your life if I see someone
walking into a pole that's the stuff
right there well especially if it's
somebody that's like supposed to know
their way around like a tour guide like
okay everybody to your ride you'll see
where a Teddy Roosevelt first tasted a
sausage
you hear that hollow sound I know you've
heard it that hollow sound and the sign
rattles on its own bolts the guy's eyes
crossed and he just slinks to the ground
like and he loves sausages ever since
and just passes out that's an unexpected
stop at joy town that's the best tour of
your life simple stuff can crack you up
if you let it like farts I know I know
I'm sorry I'm sorry I know I'm sorry I
know I'm sorry
I know Holmes does fart humor yourself
obviously all comedians want to make
cutting-edge interesting intelligent
stuff and I'm no different but that
doesn't mean I'm not gonna laugh my ass
off at a fart and an inappropriate
unexpected time why it's hilarious don't
second-guess it just like Cheryl I am
believing you thanks for making this
easier Cheryl Cheryl
[Applause]
[Music]